i'm here with shirelle mendenhall a
republican running for the u.s
senate seat thank you so much for
joining us absolutely thank you for
having me
so what makes you the best candidate to
run against catherine cortez masto
i believe i'm the best candidate because
i'm running at this with a completely
different perspective
my life has been lived in serving and
seeing a solution
like seeing a problem and being the
solution
a quick story i had a friend in los
angeles he was a single dad
and he had two little boys and he was
struggling he couldn't get a job and
he needed money and i was like okay i
want to help him but if i just give him
money right now it's a band-aid
so in the long run i ended up creating a
company
and it provided hundreds of jobs so it
was like this one need that i
saw and i created the solution so for me
i see a problem i see division i see
that we need someone to bring people
together so i'm the best person because
i'm that person and i don't quit
and i will get the job done and speaking
of bringing people together
um divided right now a lot of division
what would you
do to reach across the aisle there's a
lot of things that i want to do to reach
across the aisle but you know something
specifically that i always
show is whenever there's disaster so
i've gone and volunteered in houston
in a bunch of different states in
alabama
and whenever is an issue you don't ask
what party they are
you literally go to help and so like i
want to lead with that you guys we are
humans we are people that need help i
mean you look at the pandemic it is
absolutely devastated small business it
is collapsed so many different things
there's
you know suicide rates that have risen
so i want us to look at this as a human
issue
not let's do this like a party issue
speaking of the pandemic covid19 are you
vaccinated i am not
vaccinated and if i may
so when i was born i was actually an
identical twin and they ended up having
to cut out half of my liver one of my
adrenal glands
and my immune system has been
compromised since i was little so to add
things anytime i would get shots i would
get so sick i'd be completely laid out
so for me with the limited
kind of research at this point of the
long term and what it can
you know do to someone i have chosen not
to get it i'm as safe as possible
but that's my personal choice what is
your stance on others who
may not be in the same health situation
as you as far as getting the vaccine
so we're in america and i believe in our
freedom
i believe that we have the freedom to
choose and that's what it should be
and i do believe in taking care of
people and making sure that we don't
compromise one another
but in all honesty we cannot like impose
something that should be a right do you
uh support or
oppose additional stimulus bills being
passed for covid19 relief
that's a layered question so for me i i
feel what's happening and
since it's been so long we're
perpetuating some laziness there are
companies there are businesses that
aren't able to open because they're so
short staffed
and they're like okay well we're going
to close on friday and you know tuesday
on some of their big
days because of the fact they can't find
enough people to work
so in all honesty i think that what we
need to do is actually be putting those
jobs out there we need to cut off the
additional
stimulus and get people back to work
because people with a purpose
doing something positive in their life
which is working and bringing home money
should be what we're doing so i think we
did
you know give some stimulus we gave some
help and some aid when it was needed
but now it's time to get back to work
how concerned are you
that we will have many evictions here in
southern nevada
and what should be done um i'm very
concerned
um but there's again there's many layers
to that so the people who
were you know the owners of the
buildings they're struggling as well
you know they're like i haven't been
able to take rent you know from these
people for this duration
and now i'm in trouble so uh you know
there were a lot of stimulus
and a lot of you know aid that was given
and i do hope that they're able to put
that towards what
it should have been you know to pay for
their rent because that's
what you should be doing you shouldn't
just stop um
and what should be done i think it is
it's like
america we need to go back to work and
work hard and do what it takes
to put that roof over ahead there's a
lot of programs out there that are
actually non-profit not government
related that do
give aid and assistance to people who do
need help
in that you know meantime until they can
get that job that sustains them what's
your stance on
immigration and do you support building
a wall
i believe that there is a great process
for people to come into this country and
that needs to be adhered too
i do believe we need to build a wall
we're at you know the last number i saw
was over 700
as far as you know refugees coming to
the border uh we have drugs coming over
we have crime
and uh as a people we're we're trying to
take care of our own right now the
people who have come in here illegally
and
it's not enough we're like like you just
mentioned earlier you know about
stimulus and giving money
uh you know the implications of people
going out on the streets so
i believe we need to protect our border
have a process adhere to that
and then we can start being stronger as
a country and then we can help and give
aid to people that are in trouble
what's your stance on daca daca i'm
sorry i'm not familiar with daca
okay we'll we'll move on
nevada is more than 80 percent land
controlled by the federal
government what would you like to be
seen
done as far as that land um
well i i in all honesty just as far as
like what i've done my research on like
my
my expertise is really on like the water
issue right now so i haven't kind of
done a deep dive into the federal you
know land and
how it's being used so i don't want to
you know misspeak in this term
but the one area that i've really been
focusing on right now
is our water levels and our allocation
and things not changing since 1947 and
now we're sitting here
and some experts are stating that in
2035 we're going to be out of water
so you know with that said like whether
it's expansion
bringing in you know new new jobs to
nevada
i believe we first need to talk about
the water
issues and then we can talk about the
land and how we use it
what's the most important issue for you
um our freedom i would say that our
freedom is the biggest thing and
when i you know kind of uh was grappling
about
running for us senate i was like what am
i going to do differently than anyone
else
and i see just so many things flying on
social media and i want to build yet
another metaphoric
wall around our rights and our
privileges
for instance i believe the government is
two protectants to serve just like
you know our police before
phones were only in our tel you know in
our homes they weren't in cars
and so later when they were causing
accidents that's when
they needed to step in and put a lot in
place to protect us
from you know not driving recklessly i
think it's you know the the same thing
now
we need to build metaphoric walls around
things we didn't know we needed to
protect
for instance i love the role of a mom
a she a woman i don't want those rights
taken away
in our school system education in
government
i don't mind anybody coming up with
whatever you'd like to be called
in addition but i want to make sure my
rights to be
called a she a her a woman are protected
the right to to assemble churches you
know coming together i'm i love going to
church
and i think that people need hope in a
time like this
how do you feel about the current uh
miss nevada winner being transgender
um so for me uh something that's really
important is that we adhere by rule so
throughout all of history
you know the pageant has had in their
roles you need to be a natural-born
woman
so i i don't know that that was changed
beforehand so i really think that that
should be something that's looked at
you know because that means that the
person who did win
obviously they thought that person was
the right person but we need to go back
to the rules
that were set specifically to run in
this pageant
be a natural-born woman you're a
supporter of former president
donald trump why
so actually you know the first time he
ran
i was getting you know so much
information from both sides of what he
was you would hear in the media
you know that he hated woman he was
against this you know so many different
things so what i did
is i researched and i was like okay what
are his policies
what does he stand on what is he running
on and so that's where i first made my
decision
to support that because i believed in
his policies and the things that he
stood for
and then fast forward to the next time
and he had done so much for our economy
he had followed through on a lot of
those things it wasn't just
broken promises so for me
that's why i stood for president trump
you mentioned his policies as a woman
some of the things he said
do they offend you i i really don't get
offended you know that often because so
many people can say so many things i've
been
called so many things even since i
started in u.s senate
i don't believe offense has a place in
this for
for my personal it's more about what are
you doing for the people
what are you doing for the country he
also has elevated
a lot of women to great positions so
i like to stand on that what should be
done
about inflation i there's a lot of
okay i feel like i could talk about this
for a long time
um just kind of taking a look at what's
happening in the blocking and
uh whether it's uh you know with a
climate and things along those lines and
the implications that are happening
to gas prices we need to
do a deep dive and get to the root issue
and there are things so for me
personally i was starting a new company
and everyone's like yeah it's horrible
to get it made in america you have to go
overseas
so i believe we actually need to build
an infrastructure here take a look at
the things that are missing we have cars
that aren't being able to be made
because we can't get the chips over here
so we need to strategically take a look
at each area that we're missing here in
the united states and actually give
tax incentives to bring them back here
to be self-sustainable and that means in
crops
in manufacturing that also provides us
jobs so
i think that that is really going to
have an impact on
all the inflation that's happening tell
me about your business
so um my first one is the lead expo
talent agency
and that's the one i started because i
saw a need i also had been invited to
work a couple of
events and they're like okay we want
eight more cherelles you know to show up
and so i started bringing my siblings at
first you know my sisters
and then i was like okay i can you know
build a business around this
um and uh within one year it was it was
hard you know it was i i didn't know
what i was doing
i was learning as i went but within one
year we were nationwide
and we were providing hundreds of jobs
you know throughout the years and
it's been amazing because sometimes i
look intrinsically i'm like wow
like this was just a need that i saw
and i was able to put everything that i
am into it and to build it to today and
some people will
call them like oh my gosh you're cheryl
and i get letters so like one of them
impacted me so much in the first year
when it's like you're paying yourself
pennies
you know to to build a company and she
said because of
you i'm able to focus on my school
and not have to work my juice job you
know every single night
i can work one job a month and be able
to just focus on school
and so for me that was like that
additional thing hey keep going it's
gonna impact people
don't don't don't let you know the the
lack of moving forward
hinder you but then right after that we
just kept continuously growing and
expanding so it was pretty powerful and
i'm proud so when was that business
created and where
so i actually created it out in los
angeles uh the year
i actually i think it was about five
years ago so i don't don't
misquote me but it was about five years
ago
and started it in uh in la and then i
closed it and reopened it here in nevada
when did you reopen it here
just this past year so when i moved here
i wasn't sure
you know what was going to go on with a
pandemic things along those lines
because obviously events were no longer
in existence
so i reopened that here and we had
our first event back was out in florida
and i actually have a meeting right
after this that we're going to do a
bunch more demos so i'm excited
okay great anything else you feel like
people should know about you
personally personally um
i think that something that's important
is to not judge a book by its cover
you know i i up until this point so many
people are kind of desperating
and kind of seeing from the outside
instead of taking the time to get to
know me
i'm multi-layered i also know how to
kick off the heels
throw on some boots and get some stuff
done so whether it's building i'm gonna
be in there
demolishing or or putting you know walls
up i'll do whatever it takes
so i think that's the biggest thing to
understand me and i love people
i love our country and i want to bring
hope to a place where i see
so many people don't have it so for
people who will watch this interview
they may be surprised that you weren't
familiar with daca it's something that
affects
many people here um what do you want to
address about that do you think you
maybe have more work to do
to be taken seriously and and jump into
the race
um so i look at it as this you know when
i went to this i knew that i wasn't
going to know everything
about every single uh you know question
that i'm asked
and i see it as i have people around me
for the right reason i'm going to
appoint them they're going to advise me
and when it comes time for me to make
a decision on that i am going to
personally do that deep dive to make
sure i'm making the right decision for
the people
taking me seriously i believe that you
know my past
shows that i'm a get it done kind of
person so when that scenario arises
i will address it and do the right thing
for the people
and it's the same thing in business you
know you don't have
someone who specifically your tech
person doesn't know everything about ops
or sales you have individual people
for individual slots for a reason
and so i also don't want to um not
answer something that i don't know
anything about you know in essence to
like uh deceive the viewer okay thank
you so much for joining us yes thank you
so much